pouvant souvent d'objets connectés pour
la maison des objets intelligents qui
vous facilitent le quotidien ici j'en ai
un vous présenter un qui est intéressant
et qui était initialement dans cette
boîte là ici c'est écrit noir sur blanc
c'est le dry me botte elles disent s
ultra cet aspirateur robot j'ai plein de
choses que d'autres ne font pas il va
venir nettoyer il va venir scanner il ya
plein de technologies il ya du lit
d'ariane la caméra rgb bref il ya plein
de choses super intéressantes que je
veux dire vous détailler vous présenter
ici pour vous solutionner la vie dans
votre maison connectée
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec des limites
pour venir vous présenter cet aspirateur
robot alors vous allez voir il
intéressant qui présente souvent des
aspirateurs robots parce que ça
solutionne vraiment la vie à la maison
personnellement je déteste faire le
ménage passer l'aspirateur passer le
balai passer la serpillière qui est
vraiment tout qui ne sortent par la tête
et c'est un objet intelligents et
connectés peut faire pour moi ça me va
bien très très bien d'ailleurs je vous
montre la bête et je vous explique
comment ça fonctionne alors vous avez
effectivement un aspirateur robot on
connaîtra vous avez un lidar et si c'est
écrit sur l'eau alors c'est écrit à
l'envers mais vous avez un leader pour
la navigation c'est un laser qui va
venir à voir tous les objets et
reconnaître les objets autour de lui à
l'avant vous avez une caméra séduire gb
une caméra couleur qui va venir
identifier les objets alors vous avez de
l'intelligence artificielle
il vous l'ont écrit ici là juste là de
l'ia qui va venir reconnaître les objets
ça je vous le monde en quelques instants
sur une carte vous avez effectivement un
petit capteur ce que ça va venir taper
ici pour venir se décaler et avancer et
puis au delà de ça vous avez un truc qui
est vachement bien regarder à l'arrière
on va le prendre on va retourner là bas
une petite balayette qui va tourner et
qui va ramener les saletés par ici une
brosse en caoutchouc qui va venir tout
aspiré et ramasser et à l'arrière vous
avez deux petites serpillière qui vont
venir tourner et qui vont venir nettoyer
votre sol à l'intérieur vous avez un
petit bac avec un cochonneries qui
situent juste ici voyez avec un filtre
derrière un grand classique sur la
station et c'est là où ça devient
vachement intéressant votre aspirateur
va rentrer comme ça et là vos petits
bros elles vont venir tourner ici
tournez tournez tournez tournez pour
enlever toutes les impuretés et se
sécher comme ça il aura pas de
moisissures y aura pas d'odeur ci et ça
vous êtes tranquille donc ça c'est pour
la base mais il ya un autre truc est
extrêmement pratique c'est que vous avez
à l'intérieur je voulais montrer un
petit sac qui vient spirel et
cochonneries mais il ya une technologie
de succion qui va venir faire remonter
tout les trucs que vous avez inspiré
pour les mettre dans un sac ça vous
laisse 60 jours de tranquillité et votre
sac il est situé juste là s'est très
bien intégré c'est juste là dedans fait
prenez vous en déça il a vous avez votre
sac la voyez là commence à menacer un
peu de bazar suis tranquille j'ai pour
60 jours et à l'intérieur si je joue
bien nettoyer un peu plus regardées ils
m'ont laissé une petite brosse est là
que je peux venir récupérer pour venir
nettoyer tout ce que je veux après j'ai
plus qu'à vous positionnez en façade up
et on ne parle plus alors aux trucs qui
est bien c'est que dream qui vous a mis
un deuxième sac à l'intérieur 60 jours
ok ça c'est bien les gars vous avez
temps de voir venir avant d'en commander
d'autres et puis truc qui est très cool
ici c'est que comme vous n'avez pas vidé
votre petit bac dans votre aspirateur
directement dans votre poubelle et que
tout est ici dans un sac et bien pour
toutes les personnes qui sont
allergiques aux acariens vous n'avez pas
contact avec la poussière comme ça pas
de souci il n'y a pas de particules qui
s'échappe vous êtes tranquille et ça
c'est chouette il noté que votre sac à
poussière ici fait 3 litres donc ça
c'est la base et s'écoule maintenant il
ya autre chose qui est très c'est sous
le capot ici vous venez vous lever et
vous avez des réservoirs d'eau premier
réservoir ça c'est le réservoir d'eau
propre vous prenez l'eau du robinet vous
la mettez vous avez 2 litres et demi ici
votre aspirateur va se recharger en haut
il fait travailler une fois qu'il
revient avec de l'eau sale eh bien il
vient là mettre directement ici c'est
pareil il ya un autre truc qui est très
cool vous avez juste entre les deux
partis au milieu regardez c'est ça et ça
c'est du détergent c'est la première
fois que je vois ça sur un aspirateur
robot du détergent en règle générale
j'avais déjà coulé des choses avec d'un
côté de l'eau propre de l'eau sale je
connaissais l'histoire d'inspiration de
vie dans le sac mais je ne connais pas
encore d'aspirateurs robot j'en ai pas
testé qui ont ce système de détergent à
l'intérieur donc là vous avez un truc
est extrêmement complet c'est-à-dire que
vous aspirez vous enlever toutes les
poussières soi et appuyez vous avoir une
solution peut être un peu plus forte
versus un sol carrelage ou un parc et en
plus de ça vous avez les deux brosses
qui viennent nettoyer qui viennent
frotter avec du détergent vous injecter
de l'eau propre pour remonter de l'eau
sale bref vous avez une solution
complète total pour la maison pour bien
nettoyer grâce à un seul et même petit
objet et ça c'est extrêmement pratique
et avec cet aspirateur robot pour se
défaire 200 m² au temps de dire que là
vous avez de quoi faire toute la partie
serpillière le truc qui est intéressant
c'est que vous faites 180 tours par
minute autant vous dire qu'ici et bien
ça va venir frotter nettoyer les
briquets directement donc ça une fois de
plus c'est vachement bien parce que pour
le nettoyage en profondeur vous et pena
et comme je vous le dis je déteste
tellement cette partie de nettoyage que
vu que mon aspirateur fettouhi
l'aspirine et waif rentrer illustré
après retour au sachet sur sa basse ça
me va vachement bien le truc intéressant
ici c'est toute la partie et qui a vous
avez donc deux types de capteurs vous
allez avoir un lidar lidar saint nazaire
qui va venir scanner pour reconnaître
les volumes reconnaître les pièces
reconnaître les objets en tout cas les
cartographier puis vous avez une caméra
rgb une caméra couleur qui va bien voir
qui va reconnaître votre pièce qui
pourra faire des photos et en fait ces
deux capteurs vont bien bossé ensemble
vont passer dans la moulinette de
l'intelligence artificielle qui dès le
départ à venir cartographier votre
maison donc on aura un plan complet de
votre maison on saura où elle canapé on
saura où se situe tel et tel meuble si
bien que lorsque votre robot va passer
il n'y aura pas de doublon n'a pas
retourner là où il ya déjà été aura pas
de zones oubliées et vous allez avoir
une maximisation complète et totale du
nettoyage de votre maison un truc ici
c'est que vous avez d'inspiration qui
très puissante on se parle de 5300
pascal max alors mcgale évidemment ça va
dépendre si vous êtes sur un tapis ça va
dépendre vous allez alors je vous
montrais dans l'application parce que
pouvaient venir régler tout ça il ya une
reconnaissance du mode de tapis on peut
se dire battue on ne va pas sur les
tapis et vous avez différents types de
niveau des aspirations doué pour venir
vous personnalisés et tout en sachant et
je vous le disais les tapis les blocs at
il les reconnaît vous avez des petits
capteurs en dessous dès qu'ils arrivent
dessus il va venir adapté l'aspiration
il va arrêter la serpillière sur un
tapis il le fera sur un parquet comme
ici dont convient totalement une fois de
plus optimiser l'expérience par rapport
à votre mobilier et par rapport à vos
sols tout en sachant qu'ici on est
compatible alexa google assistant et en
syrie donc ça c'est chouette
[Musique]
tous pas dans l'application ici que vous
avez sur android mais également sur un
os qui s'appelle dream y sommes on va et
on clique dessus alors regardez vous
avez ici quand vous arrivez un plan de
notre maison ça vous donne quelques
informations je vois que j'ai le nom de
mon aspirateur robot il est en veille là
c'est mon de nettoyage pour l'instant il
n'y a rien à nettoyer parce qu'il n'est
pas en train de nettoyer 91% sens et de
la batterie qui me reste j'ai la
cartographie de mes différentes pièces
de mes différents volumes je peux gérer
les cartes donc si j'ai plusieurs cartes
voilà mais moi j'ai une carte donc on
peut se mettre ici plusieurs étages si
on a plusieurs étages si vous avez une
maison pouvait le faire ainsi très très
souhaité s'y plonge multi étages mais
ici c'est pas le cas je vais avoir
différents modes de nettoyage par
exemple si je vais sur le premier je
suis sûre du balayage pur là je suis sûr
passer la serpillière pur donc j'ai pas
aspirer je le jure nettoyer le sol ça
c'est très bien et là c'est un mix
balayage à nettoyage parce que je vous
recommande de faire vous avez ensuite
les réglages d'inspiration donc la schl
en silencieux là je suis au réglage
standard là je veux que ça à voile un
peu plus que ça va se faire fort et là
je veux le turbo et là ça va y aller
hyper fort ça va tout me ramasser pour
le mode standard mois pour l'instant de
convient bien et puis après j'ai
l'humilité des serpillières c'est le lot
je vais injecter en fait dans mes soeurs
pillèrent très humide mouillée ou alors
légèrement sèche bon ça dépendra bien
évidemment de vous de quel moment vous
voulez le faire si et ça et après vous
avez nettoyage personnalisé pouvait
venir active est ici et vous pouvez
venir régler donc il va vous faire des
recommandations intelligente
recommandation par pièce ça va dépendre
bien évidemment passer une fois la passe
et deux fois la cible de réglages
essayés ça vous avez tout à voir
directement là et après vous venez le
customiser ou choisissez ce que vous
voulez donc deux fois où il va passer
une fois deux fois trois fois par pièce
c'est vous qui voyez par exemple les
souvenirs cliquez ici suis d'abord ici
c'est la pièce de vie je veux que tu
passes trois fois parce qu'il faut
vraiment y aller je t'envoie le maximum
de flotte et key comme un dingue par
contre a contrario je veux quand tu vas
dans cet espace là et bien tu vas venir
uniquement
une fois ça sert à rien d'autre comme un
dingue et u20 mouillé comme ça et
d'inspiration normale et tu vas me faire
les deux donc on peut vraiment venir
personnaliser entièrement tout ce qu'on
veut ce soir et je trouve ça vraiment
génial vous avez également un paramètre
d'auto nettoyage de votre aspirateur
robot ça situe juste là vous activez
auto nettoyage vous définissez une zone
vous allez vous dire allez une fois que
tu m'as fait 10 mètres carrés toi qui
m'as fait vingt mètres carrés tu m'as
fait trente mètres carrés te retourne
pas nettoyé si vous voulez que ça soit
tout le temps propre parce que vos sols
et un peu dégueu vous dites que tous les
dix mètres carrés il va retrouver ses
toyer et il retourne faire le boulot ou
alors oui dans spa troquera d'août où
les 35 mètres carrés maximum sa mère a
très très bien donc ça aussi c'est pas
mal réglage aussi sur la serpillière
sèche le temps de séchage que vous
voulez et bien 2h 3h 4h la vidange du
bac le dépoussiérage la fréquence de
vidage automatique comme ça vous allez
maximiser la propre t même de votre
aspirateur robot vous avez également une
carte 3d si vous le souhaitez bon ça
c'est à vous de voir comme ça regardez
ils vous restitue un peu votre pièce moi
je vois mon canapé ma table basse m'a
bien connu à table au fond là bien les
toilettes là et là il s'est bien
positionnée juste l'a ensuite je vais
avoir ici des pièces je vais avoir des
zones se définir le nombre de passages
ici par pièce là c'est l'ensemble
directement et après je peux aller lui
dire maintenant qu'il faille dans telle
ou telle zone par exemple je veux que tu
me fasses que cette zone là qui est
vraiment très très syncope je prends ma
zone de l'étang j'arrêterai si j'ai une
petite loupe ici sa fausse a vraiment
pas mal regardez là c'est la petite
loupe je vois plus ou moins c'est très
très cool je peux rajouter des hommes
faire une séquence de nettoyage qui
passe une fois deux fois ici je peux
donner des zones restreintes par exemple
également et bien tiens je vais mettre
un mur virtuel je veux par exemple que
tu n'aille pas dans cet espace là voilà
cet espace-là open mais un but comme ça
tu n'iras pas je peux donner aussi une
zone interdite de nettoyage médias cette
zone là par exemple si tu ne vas pas
nettoyer une zone interdite de la del
sol ben tiens par exemple si tu ne vas
pas laver le sol non plus comme je te
dire complètement customisée alors
l'idée c'est pas le faire à la rage moi
par exemple j'ai pas l'envoyer dans la
chambre de mon fils qui est des lego de
tous les côtés je vais gérer
manuellement que j'ai pas envie qu'ils
viennent pousser les constructions lego
de mon fils parce que c'est un peu
compliqué donc là je m en bio virtuel
pour qu'ils rentrent pas dans la pièce
par exemple et j'ai ensuite plein de
petits réglages sont très très cool
alors les réglages de l'appareil le
fuseau horaire la voie alors moi je
l'avais laisse en anglais mais pourrait
mettre en france est très facilement au
plat j'applique la il télécharge le pack
de langues et il va l'installer en
français ajout automatique de détergents
ça je vous recommande les notifications
verrouillage enfants reprend le
nettoyage le dmd je vais avoir également
tous les paramètres de nettoyage de la
moquette la reconnaissance des tapis et
des moquettes que je vous recommande de
m l'évitement des tapis je suis pas su
évoluer qu'il adapte à la moquette faut
qu'ils viennent nettoyer quand même la
moquette un boost tapis lorsqu'il arrive
de suivre y aller un peu plus fort ce
que vous êtes à leur identification
grâce à l'ia l'environnement avec des
animaux domestiques moyens d'animal donc
voilà je vais lui dire il faut faire des
photos également lorsqu'il va dire
trouver un obstacle comme ça tu pourras
venir les consulter je peux dire
programmé mon nettoyage dire par exemple
maintien je veux que tu des toits
l'ensemble de la maison je veux que tu
fasses à telle heure je veux tu le
répètes tant de fois et je veux tel type
de nettoyage balayage face à saint
pierre balayage nettoyage passer la
serpillière après le balayage tu mon
historique de nettoyage qui est juste là
donc là je vois exactement où il est
passé quand il passe vous le voyez en
direct là où il est en train de passer
vous voyez ici il a reconnu différents
objets différents endroits de ma maison
je vais avoir la durée résiduelle je
vois part taclé moment il faut que je
vienne changer le filtre la bourse
principale la brosse latérale nettoyer
les capteurs et la serpillière il faut
savoir une fonction télécommande si joe
biden maladie à droite et à gauche je
peux bien localisé si je les ai perdus
j'appuie là il parlera bon voilà
normalement chez vous vous perdez pas
trop quand même je peux leur donner
mettre à jour vos logiciels avoir de
l'aide bref l'application est très
complète et lorsque je viens de lancer
je peux appuyer soit directement dans
l'application soit directement sur le
robot aspirateur voilà pour ce qu'il en
est aujourd'hui je voulais vous
présenter ce robot aspirateur je trouve
intéressant parce qu'une fois de plus
une fois de plus le jour où j'ai
découvert les aspirateurs robots dans la
maison ça m'a soulagé mais énormément
comme ça on s'embête plus on laisse
passer ont programmé si vous avez fait
un réglage aux petits oignons qu'il
passe quand vous l'avez décidé vous
aurez toujours une maison propre alors
il restera peut-être quelques petits
endroits à venir faire ou lui ne pourra
pas accéder je vide a fait 90 ou 95% du
ménage est fait vous êtes tranquille et
ça montre une fois de plus comment la
technologie vient vous aider vous
assister dans votre quotidien je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez comment vous
le trouvez ce que vous connaissez déjà
la marque dream une fois de plus s'il
vous intéresse mais le lien juste en bas
dans la description elle est disponible
au tarif de
1199 euros dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires et
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler tech et merci à
dreams byd avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
je vous embrasse à bientôt pour les
soins bio tchane
[Musique]